let's say the pair of come one out if
the playoffs are right now anyone out
yeah you know obviously the Lakers are
doing their thing they got a super team
over there but that doesn't excite me if
the Knicks was there same if the Knicks
had that team that still doesn't mean
that they're gonna go out and win it's
the Knicks what's up this is serge ibaka
AKA my future welcome to Alan where are
you today
I will be cooking for Action Bronson I'm
not expecting anything but happiness
enjoy that's what I hope for every day
of my life
action is sick food lover and today I'll
be cooking him bullfrog
[Music]
first step are to brew the front this is
not seafood but this leaving water - now
I'm going to make a fondue cheese sauce
let's go I know I've seen some of these
things so I'm a little bit worried to be
honest with you but I'm also interested
well here you see I'm putting up
smoothly that's how you do it now I'm
gonna take out the Frog I have only two
secrets I'm sure you know salt and
pepper we're gonna add hot cheese to the
power how are you sir
hey what's up what are you selling
welcome brother wait to see you yes sir
good to see to you see that's a good
height view I'm just good standing oh
wow yeah feel feel perfect like this
this is my this is my height right here
well you know what you can't stand
because nobody gonna know me only you
exactly how are you I'm good good yeah I
just got up I got woke up from home nap
yeah I was napping I put myself into a
little nap yeah yeah I'm glad you said
it
I want to ask you tell me are you high
come on
of course not no ok the thing is it's
not high I'm just I'm where I need to be
ok it's just here it's all about here
because if you get too much here to
there you know then you're never gonna
be there yeah it's take cost exactly
you know I see you how long you'd be
rapping you're getting a game word I've
been rapping like I don't know 10 years
now 10 years now yeah March is gonna be
the 10-year anniversary of my first
project called dr. Lecter it's actually
pretty crazy part in my language yeah
you know you Curcio know this is a pg-13
come on that's still cursed they let
through once in a while
oh they lazy 1000 just Eugene like home
alone okay so you from New York I'm from
right here how your Knicks fan of course
none of you know
yes you just kind of find out you die
for it Bernie
come on one I've been an extra yeah you
stay with you to me you stay with your
allegiance I like that yeah always what
do you think about the season so far and
the garbage this is what it is and a
young fellow rookie what do you think of
my hands it looks good looks like you
can score it's cool we need some work
but the way you seem like I'm see when
we start talking about the Nexus but
everything goes out the window you don't
think you got future I think I think he
has a future but what I'm saying is I'm
a harsh critic you know I want to see
more in to see more but he's a rookie I
know I've given him time give me time of
the oxwas rook I need to see more three
years later I need to see more all right
I like John rank I think he's a game
changer like an adversary he's just
tough I wanted the next to get him
that's the guy beside there the Knicks
right now yeah all right let's see the
pair come on out it's the playoffs right
now anyone out yeah you know obviously
the Lakers are doing their thing they
got a super team over there but that
doesn't excite me
no because it doesn't well you know it's
not fair it's not fair you say it's that
you're saying that because it's not your
team if the Knicks was there same if the
next had that team
yeah what do you say I would acknowledge
that it wasn't fair but that still
doesn't mean that they're gonna go out
and win it's the Knicks but come on it's
all about having those right amount of
guys those guys that gel like you know
with the serrano jean guys they're just
Joe you know a couple of stars on team
but other than that good gel
it's like la look did you see did I see
your glory the awesome of course yeah
watch the whole playoffs it was all yeah
I mean no why is that guy cause why is
that guy you played unbelievable thank
you
you know it was a lot of a siakam van
the one Freddy Beverly yeah yeah that's
gotta say in say no Mandalay crazy
family Noah Wanderlei what's his name
yeah like you say family he did his
thing yeah he played that that's what it
takes it takes people to come out of the
Woodworks and just give an unbelievable
performance that was unexpected
yes and that's what it takes it took
that shot and in Philly a kowai shot oh
that's crazy I was like it was like
you're leaning until it goes in heavy
duty lots of drama it was fun let's find
out
so Nick's fans yes but just give credit
or Nick's the move they did this summer
why just give them credit I can't give
any credit some night no no anything
okay but okay great yeah obviously we
want the k2 here that's what we want we
wanted that too well here right yeah but
we didn't get it
so I'm sour yeah Kairi is still he's
taking off when he wants he's told you
that I'm watching it
no you're watching oh you from the
social media and news I don't look at
that type of stuff I look at memes
I don't look at like sports social media
i watch with my own eyes yeah I just
know what I see
Kyrie needs to stop playing more you
know he's trying to be noisy gonna be
the floor general huh what are you doing
with him what happened what happened he
was hurt right knows that's what they
say that's why they say exactly faked
knee injuries as well if I did a move
and I missed the shot oh my hamstring
listen at the end of the day yeah you
just want to see good basketball you
want to see people that are on the team
play every day because that's about
right yeah but dude I'm gonna tell you
something you know is it allowed when
you when you watch basketball you watch
cosplay now I'm talking to a person an
athlete of course when you watch us play
you know we play with large things going
on how fun sometimes you guys don't know
oh gosh right yeah you think I'm doing
this I'm fully healthy right now
I'm on the injury report right now to my
brother you know I got come here with a
hurt foot but I still played through it
he's still coming if I'm not sure that's
the thing and I'm not gonna tell anybody
you know that was supposed to be hidden
I wasn't even limping I came in ready
just in case we were gonna run up
one-on-one or something you don't even
understand my jump shot has been wet
since age 7
[Music]
what conspiracy listen the first time I
stepped foot into Madison Square Garden
yeah I went 8 for 12 three-point against
who just by myself
just but come on as soon as I stepped on
the court
poof fish there's no games so what and
get payer would you compare to again
[Music]
Allen Iverson yeah because you know he
doesn't need to really practice he was
kind of born with he was born this way
yeah you know so I'm gifted in all these
facets as well you're rappers chef
author TV star yeah how did we get
casted in a freshman movie
yeah the Irishman I mean Irishman right
yeah that's how you get cast in a movie
Irishman I don't know I guess they liked
my look so my look wish this look with
this look it fit the theme of the movie
and it fit that part so when we when we
watch movie that's at the cost people
buy the look - of course they cast
people buy the look you know you're
going for I went in and read yeah it was
I bombed it was terrible but they still
gave me a part maybe I wasn't as bad as
I thought
do you do you have fun doing that didn't
rain yeah it was incredible it's like me
and DeNiro right here to each other like
I had to walk you know how hard it is
for someone to be telling you that you
have to do a walk and talk so who's like
this literally a headlines I had a story
here and then I'm giving them all kinds
of things I'm talking like this bla bla
bla bla bla
and I gotta hit certain points I gotta
make sure I look at the camera
exposed my left side you know what I
mean it's not an easy thing it's hard
yes we knocked it out in like four takes
you know we don't like to do too many
because you know once you get it you get
it if you don't get you don't
so now it's time for how spicy Christian
mmm okay I'm gonna ask you a questions
yeah you have to awesome okay if you
don't know sir
I have a surprise for you okay this is
your beer it's your own dream
okay but you mix it with some it's mixed
with crickets no no I just like those
okay and spicy this is your um ah were
they fumble or from Congo yeah
originally I have never had a Congo
cricket okay then
are you ready it better not be math
problems I'm good at jeopardy okay what
was the worst artist you have be done
it's always the worst one was like me
I'm gonna just start saying random names
I Leonardo he was terrible wasn't it
Leonardo
yeah he wasn't a rapper he was a singer
it was from France from France yeah man
it was terrible are you making those
names no I'm serious are you making
wait are you do you get to also combat
whether I'm saying the right thing or
I'm answering the question Leonardo did
I don't okay cut no no what song what
song
Leonardo what song it's called don't
lean on my shoulder
no I'm serious by there can you go get
me that song no no no
what is this might as well try this
go ahead it's good I like it
what's the next question goodnight yeah
I do okay there's a leg yeah the leg
there's a wing it's another one last one
you ready
can you rap a freestyle about the NBA
right now like this why now no if you're
a purist you do when you want and when
you feel not when someone asks I mean
I'm asking nicely please yeah but okay
please
yes but that's making me want to do it
less trust me I don't know absolutely
not okay put more put more let them soak
for a second the juice is actually good
before you put before you take that beer
I couldn't even tell
can you tell because we mix it they're
good that's good yeah you want to try it
try make come on let me take the one
that doesn't have too much I'm sorry
Bureau now I like that if you fry those
up with some ginger scallion and garlic
all right I'm mad that's good
Diane come in bring it in
yes sir all right hungry are you I'm not
that hungry I had a little something
before I came all right yeah just to do
something I heard you like seafood right
I gotta be honest with you I hate
seafood I do not eat seafood
you asked me if I liked it no okay well
I try it yes yes all right tonight I
could from fondue for you Oh see I think
that this is prepared in a proper way
oh yeah it's called way to wooden make
like it's just let me just be honest
with you it's not hot I would love to
try that but that seems to be in the
temperature danger zone I'm serious I'm
certified by the board try it give it a
try
that looks like a good little nugget
right there oh you go come on you know
I'm going for the hamster no look at my
own wait why are you holding my weight
hey don't move I got something for you
don't move I know you can make a little
crostini now you can't do it it's
everybody feeling be careful it's hot it
tastes pretty good
yeah well told you what is it huh listen
there it's a fun day it's cheese cheese
and what what type of trees grew yeah
it's a great cheese it's good right
crostini yeah let me give you the
hamstring it's the best part
yeah I'm getting that one hey come on I
got you have that present it's fire
that's tremendous that's a good job man
I'm very happy with that
[Applause]
[Music]
take some of that bread and try some of
this out of the world for me please
dunk the bread in that olive oil please
immediately use your brain i curated
this with a friend of mine named
Nicholas Coleman okay here's the top
audiologist in this world this oil right
here is one of Sicily's most rare olives
you eat that it's gonna be good for your
brain you know you're gonna be able to
make faster decisions on the court so
Jordan it's also good for your skin your
skin everything you put it on the baby's
head no this may be an olive oil just
hold it by the foot and just dunk Marius
this was great guys yeah I really
appreciate it come on man well for the
55th time get the stun camera in here
but we've we're just holding this now
look at this my forearms
thank you thank you say again